لاول مره قنابل ذكيه بعيده المدى في
طريقها الى اوكرانيا كجزء من حزمه
المساعدات الامريكيه والتي سيعلن عنها في
اقرب وقت وفق ما كشفته الامريكيه السلاح
الذكي هذه المره هو عباره عن قنبله ذات
قطر صغير او كما تسمى
اطلاقها من الارض وهي قنبله موجهه بدقه
تزن 250 رطلا ومثبته بصاروخ يبلغ مداه 94
ميلان وهو ابعد من اي قنبله قدمتها واشنطن
حتى الان يمكن اطلاق القنبله من قاذفات
صواريخ مثل نظام هاي مارس الذي قدمته
واشنطن في وقت سابق القنبله مجهزه ايضا
باجنحه تسمح لها بالانزلاق نحو اهدافها
بدقه عاليه ومحرك صاروخي لمنحها قوه
اضافيه كما تحتوي ايضا طبعا على انظمه
تتبع متقدمه تم تطوير القنبله الذكيه على
السنوات الماضيه من قبل شركه بوين
بالشراكه مع اي بي السويديه اما تصنيعها
فهو في الولايات المتحده ومنذ بدايه الحرب
مشاهدينا في اوكرانيا ترددت واشنطن
بتزويدها باسلحه بعيده المدى بسبب مخاوف
من اكياف قد تستخدم هذه الاسلحه لضرب
اهداف داخل الروسي مما يؤدي طبعا الى صدام
مباشر بين كل من موسكو والغرب لكن هذه
القنبله ربما قد تغير من تلك السياسه
والتردد الامريكيه